all right we're gonna go ahead and get
started I want to start the class with
some stuff about some logistics as well
as sort of to address some questions
that have come up on Piazza about the
grades on the midterm and some people
have concerns about what that might mean
for their grades on the final class um
it was interesting to go back and
compare the means and the distributions
on the midterm last year it's near
identical so last year in the mean was
about 69% this year it was about 71% you
see pretty similar distributions the one
on the top is our no the one on the
bottom is ours so you can see this is
this is 2018 so look pretty similar
distributions um we don't do an official
curve for the class if anybody's getting
over 90% I always consider even if
everybody gets over 90% that that means
that those people all understand the
material well enough to deserve an A and
then if we have really abnormal
distributions that sometimes we curve
below that but just to give you a sense
last year about 42% of people got an A
in the class so for those of you that
are concerned about your midterm
performance and concerned about your
final grade and whether it's still
possible to do well in the class it
definitely is so because then we have
any questions about the midterm I know
we've had some regrade regrade requests
and we're going through those as quickly
as we can is there any distribution
available per per question because I I
feel like for example for me I just I'll
double-check with the CAS that there's
no reason we shouldn't release that I
don't think there is so we grades go
gives us full distributions for all the
questions so we can really set a lot of
people ran out of time the last problem
was definitely the hardest so that was
where we saw the biggest variation and
so that's where we tried to be
particularly careful on the rubric and
we very much try to make sure that if
you're doing algebraic mistakes
throughout the exam that that was worth
very little and we were focusing on the
conceptual understanding any other
questions about the midterm so I'll just
write down per per problem breakdown
basically when we're going through it we
tried to look at any problem that had
really high variance and then step
through that
rubric again to make sure that we are
being fair oh one other things I which
is we're going to continue to accept
regrade requests for the midterm through
Friday okay so that's the midterm
hopefully that helps sort of quell some
concerns from at least some of people in
the class the other thing that I wanted
to bring up right now is the quiz so the
quiz is gonna be in about two weeks a
little less than three weeks
it's a weird format we do this for a
reason I think one of the big tensions
and classes that have big final projects
is whether to do a big final project and
a big final exam which i think is a lot
of a lot for students to do both on and
otherwise why go to class after the
midterm I mean oh why cut white you know
how do we make sure that there's a
reason to learn about the material in
the second half of the course which we
do think is valuable and particularly as
it often covering more important recent
topics but without doing a really high
stakes large exam so I talked to a
number of people in the sort of teaching
the teaching center here called VP TL
and the idea that we came up with is to
do a low stakes quiz and the idea is
that it's fun and I've heard from
multiple people that this is actually
true that's the design of it the design
is it's gonna be a two-part quiz it's
multiple choice it's all supposed to be
about sort of high level conceptual
questions we'll release last year's so
you guys can see an example and so the
idea is you do it in two parts you first
do it individually that takes around 45
minutes and then you'll be paired up
with random groups and you will have to
do one joint quiz and your grade will be
composed both of your individual part
and your group part but you can only do
better on your group part so if your
group does worse then you're gonna just
get the same as your individual grade so
the reason that we do this is that for
the group then it's a scratch-off exam
so you scratch off answers as you decide
on them is a group and the point is to
that you should be able to articulate
why you believe some of these answers
are true or false and convince your
classmates and in doing so that can be a
really useful way to think about really
knowing the material well and also here
in the respect
of other people so that's how the last
quiz goes again last year everybody
there was some concern about it before
on Piazza people were concerned there
are certain game theoretic aspects that
can come up we carefully design this so
that it's a very small part of your
grade
again you could only do better with the
group then you can on your individual so
it's carefully constructed and
empirically when we did this there was
lots of laughter and lots of people
seemed to really enjoy this aspect and
we thought about whether we'll do it in
multiple parts of the class but it's
different almost nobody has ever done an
exam like this so doesn't me have any
questions about that it's about 5% of
your grade already decided the question
was how are the teams assigned and have
we already decided them we'll do that by
random assignment it'll depend also on
which SCPD students are taking the exam
on campus or not but we will release
this a few days before and you'll be
randomly allocated to a team and then
you'll just sit with that team for that
part of the exam may have any other
questions about that and well it will
release the the sample one it will cover
all of the course so it'll be more
heavily weighted to stuff that's
happened since the midterm but anything
from the whole course will be game and
the idea is that someone who has been
attending lectures or watching lectures
online should have to study for you know
on the order of a few hours and then be
pretty well prepared for the exam you'll
also be able to bring a cheat sheet just
like what you did for the midterm there
any other questions about that yeah and
I feel like you promised me this but I'm
just missing which part of the quiz is
individual versus other people do we sit
down individually and then after like 20
minutes go so good one so how does what
is this individual group thing so the
idea is that you come in everybody gets
an exam you work on that exam probably
from around 45 minutes you hand it in
when you're done then when everybody
when that part of the the class is done
most people finish early it depends
then you as a group get a new exam and
you do exactly the same exam as before
but you just have to jointly agree on
the answers and you scratch it off so we
can see how many it's how many got to
scratch off until you got the right
answer but essentially we can just see
whether or not you got their answer on
the first time or it took more than one
any other questions about the quiz you
have any concerns about that just write
and email us on Piazza I'll just say
briefly there about what was the one of
the concerns that came up last year I'm
the concern was game theory so you
always get the max of your score versus
the the group score so what people said
is well what you should do is you should
answer the best you can on your
individual part because that's worth the
most credits and then on the group part
you should if you were torn between two
you should get people to agree on the
second answer to hedge your bets you can
do that if you want to or try to your or
your group members can outweigh you
again the group part last year was about
0.5% so it's very small so there there
is that possibility you would only want
to do that if you were genuinely really
torn between two options and again
there's only one right answer so I I
think that we observed in practice there
was very little need to do game
theoretic analysis of this but no again
we're always welcome to hear how people
interpret these things all right any
other questions about the quiz or
logistics right now we also most of you
who have already turned in your
milestone for the project will be giving
feedback on those over the next few days
for those of you that are not doing the
default ok all right so I put this up
before this is for everybody that didn't
see it before
the great distribution is basically
identical so today we're going to do the
last part on fast learning this is a
really big topic there's tons of work on
it
well we'll spend some more time on it
today and then on Monday Chelsea Finn
who's just finished up her PhD at
Berkeley and she'll be joining faculty
here in the summer will come and talk
about meta learning which is also a
really exciting area and she'll be
talking about meta learning for
reinforcement learning where meta
learning is relevant to sort of
multitask or transfer learning tasks
so just to go refresh our minds about
what we're talking about in terms of
this fast learning we're thinking about
cases where data matters so things like
health care and education and customers
I was giving an invited talk at
Pinterest on Monday they definitely care
about these types of ideas as well and
we've been talking about two different
settings Bandits and Markov decision
processes as well as frameworks for
formally understanding whether an
algorithm is good or whether it is fast
in terms of the amount of data it needs
and I'll note there that we haven't
talked much about computational
complexity for this part of the course
but there is similar some of these
frameworks can even easily be extended
to talk about polynomial sample
complexity so often you can extend these
frameworks to also account for
computational complexity of requirements
okay so let's continue with Markov
decision processes well we started seen
last time is that we built up through
this expertise on bandits so far of
thinking of a couple of the main ways we
evaluate whether or not a bandit
algorithm is good and approaches to try
to achieve that so we talked about
mathematical regret which was the
difference between how well we could
have acted and how well we did act in
bandits and a lot of the work in bandits
focuses on regret we also talked about
two different types of techniques for
trying to achieve low regret which was
optimism under uncertainty I
and then also Thompson sampling so
trying to be Bayesian and explicitly
represent posterior over what you think
might happen when you pull an arm or
take an action and using that sort of
information then last time we started
talking about Markov decision processes
where I argue that very similar ideas
are important here but but the problem
is a lot more challenging in many ways I
and we were talking a little bit about
probably approximately correct
so in particular we were talking a bit
about model-based interval estimation
which I mentioned was a probably
approximately correct algorithm and so
just to remind ourselves what did PAC
mean
and some of you have seen this probably
a machine-learning
so probably approximately correct
probably approximately correct RL
algorithm is one that given an input
epsilon and delta so epsilon is going to
specify sort of how good we post optimal
we want to be and Delta is going to
specify with what probability we're
gonna want this to occur with input
epsilon Delta on all but n steps our
algorithm will select an action where
there the Q value of that action the
true optimal Q value it was greater than
or equal to right Donna is B the best
possible you could have for that state
minus Epsilon
with probability at least one minus
Delta and throughout today I'm gonna be
a little bit loose about constants
sometimes this will be 1 minus 2 Delta
sometimes that might be a little
constant in front of here sometimes
there might be a little constant part of
there I'll put one here just so you keep
that in mind there might be small
constants there those are just they
might be 2 or 4 but the important thing
is that that you're clothed beary close
to optimal except for maybe a constant
factor away where n is a polynomial
function s size of your state space size
of your action space gamma slide I guess
great so freshmen was good is are these
gonna depend on epsilon or Delta or 1
over epsilon or 1 over Delta yes inside
of all the expressions they'll end up
being 1 over epsilon and 1 over Delta so
you could equally write this as this
because essentially n is gonna be larger
if you want to be more accurate so
that's gonna as epsilon gets smaller
you're gonna need more data to be more
accurate and if you want to be more sure
you're gonna be accurate you're gonna
also scale up with that Delta okay and I
just wanted before we kind of continue
further I'd like to briefly contrast
this with regret because in the bandit
setting we mostly think about regret but
it's nice to think about what the
difference is between pack and regret
particularly an online learning meaning
like our algorithms learning online at
an MDP and it's learning forever which
is what regret is telling you so regret
is saying that large enough in the back
okay so what regret is saying is let's
say we start off at a state s 0 regret
is saying what if you did the optimal
thing from then onwards and like how
great would your life have been so if
you had won that you know first coloring
contest then that set you up for Harvard
and it set you up for the Supreme Court
like it's fabulous but if instead you
didn't enter that that
coloring contest and you've got down
here instead so you could have had like
a +10 there but instead you had a zero
and you went to a different state which
or you went to a different state in
terms of an MDP where now you are not
the person that won the coloring contest
and so then you know your life
trajectory was irreversibly ruined in
this case you are judged with respect to
not just the actions but the state
distribution you could have got to under
the optimal policy so you're always
being judged with what could I have
reached if from the very beginning I
always made optimal decisions I always
went into that coloring contest I always
went to Harvard you know I never went to
that Stanford place and and you got up
to the Supreme Court versus as soon as
you make a different decision you might
end up in a different states
distribution but you're gonna look at
these gaps so you're gonna be judged by
the state distribution you ended up in
and the rewards you got there versus the
state distribution you'd get in under
the optimal policy in their words you
get there so regret in some ways is a
pretty harsh criteria because it's
saying like you always have to be judged
for like if you'd made optimal decisions
forever
pack is much more reasonable in certain
ways pack says I'm judging you under the
state distribution you get you under
your algorithm so because it says it'll
take an action that's close to optimal
for the state that you're in so what
does pacts a pact says okay you started
off here you didn't enter the coloring
contest you went to there okay that's
too bad
given that you could have then you know
I don't know enter the next coloring
contest or you didn't and I'm gonna be
judged by that local gap I'm going to
always only be judged by how optimal am
i given the distribution of states I'm
getting to under my algorithm so PAC can
give have much smaller regret there's
like a much smaller sort of negative
differences compared to regret because
imagine you have a really harsh MDP and
you have to make the first right move
and then you go to some wonderful land
LC you always toil about in this
horrible good world so in that case
regret would compare you to if you'd
actually made the right first choice
whereas pack would say okay maybe made a
bad first choice but like you're making
the best of things for where you're at
and you're kind of being near optimal
given this bad state space you ended up
in so in some ways you can think of pack
is kind of making the most of the
circumstances you but got yourself into
where as regret is always judging you
from with you'd make good decisions from
the beginning that's a question back
there yeah and everyone please remind me
of your names I know I'm trying hard but
I sometimes forget yeah great question
question is does this extend to episodic
MVPs um so in episodic on DPS just to
recall those are MVPs where we act for H
steps or a finite number of steps and
then we reset in episodic
mdps regret and Packer closer because
normally the pack guarantees we get in
that case I'm not going to talk too much
about those today but are going to be
with respect to the starting state so
you're gonna look at like B stars as 0
vs Q star of s 0 it's like the actions
you're taking or the policy you're
following so in those cases they start
to be closer because you're always being
judged from the starting state and you
can reset but in online like continual
learning for reinforcement learning they
can be quite different
because the state distributions can be
so different oh yeah I just put about C
1 and C 2 you
I just I'm gonna be very loose with
constants today most of these types of
regret guarantees are all about orders
of magnitude so it's stuff like is n a
function of s to the sixth or is it a
function of s to the 4 and we generally
don't worry about constants too much so
I just put these in there to say some of
the different theoretical bounds will
have different constants there but for
DES we're just gonna kind of ignore
those but just so that you know that
there may be constants there this might
be 1 minus 2 Delta for example instead
of 1 minus Delta
all right so that's one of the
differences between regret and pact so
let's go back to this algorithm now and
I'll highlight so we'll talk a little
bit about generalization later today but
I wanted to go through sort of one of
how old we start to think about whether
an algorithm is pac---- or not I told
you that this algorithm is PAC but I
want to talk some about why it's PAC and
what it means for an algorithm to be a
PAC and are there general sorts of
templates that we can use to show an
algorithm is PAC all the stuff I'm going
to talk about right now involves tabular
settings where we can write down the
value function as a table and later
we'll talk some about how these ideas
extend we're particularly picking this
algorithm which is what's known as a
reward bonus algorithm so we have this
nice little reward bonus here because
it's going to be easier to extend to the
model free case now one thing I just
want to highlight when we look at the
MBI a/b is that if we go back and
refresh our memories about this what we
were doing is we are computing the
maximum likelihood estimate or otherwise
known as just adding up the counts and
dividing of the empirical estimate of
the transition model and the reward
model for every state action pair so we
look at how many times we've been in the
state action pair which next dates we
transition to and we use that to
construct an empirical model and we do
the same for the reward structure and
then we want to figure out how to act we
take those empirical models and you can
think of this this operator here as if
we're slightly changing our reward model
so I put it here is the empirical reward
plus this bonus you can alternatively
think of this is like an R hat prime
which is equal to our hat of si plus
this bonus term so you can make a
businesslike kind of defining a new MDP
there's a new MDP where the transition
model is t hat and the reward model is
our hat prime which is the empirical
reward plus this bonus term and that's
it's not a real MVP but but that's an
MDP we could solve and try to compute
the optimal value for and that's what
we're doing here as we construct this
sort of optimistic MDP where we're using
the empirical transition model and then
we used a reward model that has really
large bonuses in places we haven't
visited very much alright and and a key
thing we're gonna see shortly is the
critical thing is how optimistic to be
and there's been tons of work on on
trying to make things more or less
optimistic and we have time I'll show
you some other slides about so recent
progress in this field ok so we talked
before about this bean pack and then now
let's talk a little bit about sort of
what are the sufficient conditions to
make something pack and then how does MB
ie B satisfy those form of conditions so
the conditions that I'm going to talk
about are derived basically from this
paper with slight modifications that
paper does not I'll just break down here
does not analyze m bi EE B so things
would have to be a little bit different
but from a 30,000 foot perspective this
is basically a reasonable way to think
about why M bi e is maie EB is a PAC
algorithm so let's unplug this or yeah
once I plug this induce on the board cuz
I think it's helpful to kind of see all
of it at once ok so what is the
sufficient set of conditions to make
something PAC
I know that I found this paper super
helpful when I was starting to do the
pack proofs in my PhD so so what's a
sufficient conditions for packing and
the theory is beautiful but even for
those of you that aren't interested in
the theory I think looking at this is
helpful because it gives one an
intuition about what types of properties
geographers need to have in order to be
efficient or what what types of
properties are sufficient for your
algorithm to be efficient okay so the
first one is optimism again this is not
the only set of conditions that are
sufficient that are sufficient for
something to be packed but here's a set
here's optimism okay and optimism simply
says that the computed values okay so
this is for this is s T this is a T so
this is the actual value we compute like
from MBIA be that optimistic value we
compute so this is the computed value of
your algorithm has to be greater than or
equal to the true optimal value for that
state action pair minus epsilon on all
time steps so it says that whenever
we're doing that MBI Eby calculation
when we take in our empirical models and
we add in that reward bonus we have to
pick a reward bonus so that whatever we
compute for the resulting state action
pair is optimistic - mmm salon on all
time steps all of this is only going to
need to hold with high probability but
I'll just write it out like this so this
is the first condition the second
condition is a little bit more subtle
but I'll say more in a second about the
specific cases for this so the second
thing is what's known as accuracy all
right down accuracy first so the first
thing says you need to be optimistic
about all time steps the second thing is
you need to be accurate which means the
VT this is again what the algorithm
computes
your algorithm is gonna compute this
this is what MBI computes using your
optimistic model needs to be minus V PI
T of a weird MDP I'm gonna tell you what
that about that weird MVP in a second it
is not the MDP I just said that is the
nice optimistic MVP it is not the real
MVP it is an MVP that's sort of in the
middle of those and this type of trick
in RL comes up a lot where we sort of
construct you've seen probably in
several proofs now where we add and
subtract the same term which is sort of
halfway in between say two different
markov decision processes we're gonna
play a similar trick here and we're
gonna construct an MDP that is sort of
half optimistic and is half like the
real MVP again this doesn't exist in the
real world we're just going to use it as
a tool for our analysis so I'll say what
this is shortly what there's different
ways to define this but it says that
something that's going to be closely
related to both your optimistic MVP and
the true MVP that your value so this is
high T is the policy you're actually
executing at time step T that the value
you compute has to be close to this sort
of weird hybrid MDP within epsilon so it
has to be pretty close to this other MDP
and the reason for this is that this is
we're gonna be able to use this to try
to bound how far away we can be from the
real MVP so why are we gonna need this
we're gonna need this because optimism
would be easy to hold by just studying
our values super high and never updating
so that's fine but you need to be able
to use the information you have so that
eventually you're gonna be acting near
optimally so if something really is bad
you don't want to be really optimistic
forever and so the accuracy condition is
gonna say if we've got sort of enough
information about some state action
pairs our value for some of those needs
to be fairly close to a real values
and then the third thing
it's founded learning complexity this
has two parts
this says the total number of updates
total number of cute updates so in MB
IAB we would update our state action
values and we would rerun that sort of
optimistic Q value iteration the total
number of times we do that has to be is
going to be bounded as is the number of
times we visit an unknown pair state
action pair and I'll say more what that
is in a second so we're gonna classify
all state action pairs and we're in the
tabular settings that this is reasonable
for us to do we're gonna end up
classifying every single state action
pair into being either known or unknown
and we're gonna say the total number of
times we visit an unknown state action
pair both of these have to be bounded by
some function this is a function of
epsilon and Delta so it means you can't
do an infinite number of Q updates and
you can't visit unknown state action
pairs an infinite number of times like
your algorithm can't these are
conditions on your algorithm okay so if
you can satisfy all of these then your
algorithm is pac---- so if 1 through 3
are satisfied then you'll be absolute
order epsilon optimal on all but and
I'll write this out here just so you can
kind of get a sense of what these type
of bounds can look like at all but n
which is equal to order this Lert this
is bounded sample complexity
/ epsilon times 1 minus gamma squared
times some log terms so essentially this
is saying that if you can be optimistic
accurate with respect to some weird MVP
I haven't told you about and that if
your total number of queue updates and
the number of times you visit under the
state action pairs which I haven't
haven't told to you about exactly how
weird to find that if that is bounded
then you're gonna be PAC you're gonna be
near optimal on all time steps except
for a number that scales as a function
of this which is also generally a
function of the size of the state's base
in action space this is also function
and epsilon of 1 minus Delta so this is
kind of a template so if you couldn't
show that your algorithm satisfies these
properties and you can show that it's
PAC all right so how does MB ie B
satisfy these properties well the first
thing we need to show is that m bi e EB
is optimistic yeah question so the first
question was a 4-3 parallel to they both
have same balance just like different
good question asking about do you mean
the epsilon their visit state action
pairs they are going to be very closely
related essentially whenever you visited
on state action pair then you can do a Q
update in 1 & 2
the questioner was our epsilon is the
same yes they're the same epsilon is
same through 1 2 & 3 so if you're
designing your algorithm 1 & 2 & 3 all
have to be the same constants probably
don't matter it can you know be why mice
in some of these cases you can be have a
constant in front of the epsilon 1 just
has to be a bit careful so for here
we'll just put them like that same
epsilon everywhere
okay so let's talk first about why MBI
eb is optimistic let's actually can we
put this up please I think that'll be
better so I'm gonna just reap it up MB
II's bonus term so that you can see what
that looked like okay so I think this is
gonna go up in just a second and then
just remind us what the update was for
per qulet first so in what we were doing
in mb ib is we had the state action pair
we had our empirical reward for that
state action pair plus our bonus o beta
divided by square root of n SI thought
you spawn the backers that okay okay
okay great i feel least one person
nodding so this is our sort of
optimistic reward you can call this like
our tilde this is our optimistic reward
plus sum over s prime this is our again
empirical transition model s prime given
s a max over a prime of q tilde of s
prime a prime okay so this would be a
backup we could do this was like a
bellman backup with our optimistic
reward bonus and just to remind
ourselves beta was going to be defined
as 1 over 1 minus gamma square root of 1
half log 2 s a divided by delta all
right so in this case what we want to be
able to show we don't have to think
about known or unknown state action
pairs yet we want to show that this
value when we compute it is an upper
bound to the true Q star up to epsilon
so we want to be able to show this first
optimism condition no no we're trying to
argue right now is that that beta is
sufficiently large as a bonus that when
we do this procedure we're going to be
optimistic
so let's okay so how do we show that
let's think about a particular state
action pair so let's think about one
state action pair so si and let's think
about that we visited some and si x
which is less than M so in our algorithm
we are only going to update our
empirical estimates until we have n
samples so we only use the first M
samples of si to compute R hat and after
that we're gonna throw away our data so
this is like saying the first M times
you visit this particular state action
pair you can use that data to try to
compute an empirical model use it to
compute an empirical model before you
have M counts but after that you're
never gonna update I'll just put a side
note in there which is um you might
think why why should we do this and in
particular there's a really lovely
description of the whole field of
machine learning by Tom Mitchell who's
one of the really the founders that
machine learning where he argues the
whole discipline of machine learning the
point is to look at the foundations of
how an agent can learn and also that we
design algorithms that continue to
improve with more data and this is
violating that to some extent because
this is saying that even if you get ten
trillion examples of that state action
pair which surely would make your
empirical model better we're gonna throw
all that data out just to give you a
sense of why we do that or why this
earlier analysis did that we do that for
the high probability bound the idea is
that the high probability bound is going
to work like what we saw for bandits of
making sort of upper confidence bounds
and kind of guaranteeing that our
estimates say of the transition model
are close to the true values and those
bounds all hold with high probability
so who here is seen Union bounced in
different things okay a few people but
most people not so union bounds are a
way to make sure that if you have a
number of different events all of which
hold with high probability that the
total of those events all hold with high
probability and that is essentially why
here we only use a finite amount of data
intellectually this is completely
unsatisfied because you should clearly
be able to use more data and your
algorithm should do better with using
more data and empirically we use all the
data one thing that I find really
satisfying for the last few years is
that
for Lattimore who's over who's one of
the authors of the Bandit book that we
recommend we showed that you can remove
this restriction
you couldn't just continue to use data
forever by using smarter things than
Union bounce but regardless for today
we're going to do this so we're gonna
say we're only gonna use up to M samples
now let's think about cases where an MSA
is less than or equal to X okay so we
have up to M samples but in general you
know might be one it might be to some
number that is smaller than M which is
some constant that we have not specified
yet okay so what we're gonna look at is
for this state action pair we're gonna
look at all of the experiences for that
state action pair so let's call X I to
be defined to be RI plus gamma v star of
s I this should look quite like what the
sort of targets that we had in TV
learning this is saying that the reward
we got on the ice time we sampled SN a
and the next state we got to on the ice
time we sampled SN a this is from the
next state okay so we can define this so
you can think of each of these are gonna
have an expectation of the true Q star
of Si because I've just defined this we
don't have to know what V Star is right
now we're just analyzing what would
happen with these samples so if we
define our samples to be are the real
reward we saw the real next state we saw
on average this is really just Q star of
Si all right so if this is Q star of Si
we can think about how many samples do
we need until we have a good
approximation of Q star si or how far
away can our average be over the average
the real empirical average of x i's
versus Q star and we can do this using
HOF ting or other sorts of deviation
bounds a little bit like what we saw off
for bandits so for bandits we looked at
if you have a district
rewards if you have a finite number of
samples of that how far can it be away
from the true mean reward and similarly
here we're gonna say if you have a
finite number of samples of the next
state and the reward received how far
away can we be from the true q-star
in this case alright so there's some
technical details here because one has
to be a little bit careful about the
fact that the data that we gather
depends on the history so this is again
one of the more challenging things in
Markov decision processes in this sense
or particularly Markov decision
processes in that the data you gather
depends on your algorithm so you're
gonna get more samples for state action
pairs that you think are gonna be good
less samples for state action pairs that
you think you're gonna be bad
so there's coupling the data isn't
really iid across the whole distribution
but sometimes conditioned on the fact
that we're sampling for the state action
pair the next state and reward or iid
because it's Markov so just to give some
that's just to say we have to be a
little bit careful here but we can
basically do the product use things like
Huff ting to say the probability that Q
star of Si minus 1 over n si sum over I
equals 1 to n si of X i where x i's are
just what we defined up there the
probability that's greater than or equal
to beta over square root of n si it's
going to be less than or equal to the
exponential minus 2 beta squared 1 minus
gamma squared this is using like HOF
ting or a similar type of deviation
inequality you can also use ones that
depend on martingales
for those of you that have seen some of
those before regardless this basically
just allows us to say as you get more
and more samples for this particular
state action pair how far away could you
be from optimal if you did know B star
now we know what beta is I put it up
there so if we plug beta into here so if
you plug beta in the real value for beta
you get that this is going to be equal
to Delta divided by two sides of the
state space size of the action space at
M so it just says that this holds with
high probability that the number as you
have more samples the probability that
you're going to be far away from the
true Q star is small alright so we can
put that like substitute this result
back in and we can say what that
therefore means is that if we look at
the Union bound across all of this well
here let me just write down one more
thing which is what does this X I
actually look like
so X i if you say 1 over n si of sum
over I equals 1 to n si affects I what
is that that's actually just the
equation that we had up there so it's
very similar to it's your empirical
reward plus gamma times t hat s Prime si
almost that equation separate got V star
here so this should look really similar
to that q tilde up there we're using the
empirical rewards here in the peripheral
transition the difference is that here
we're using Q star and up there we're
using Q tilde alright so what this means
is that if you have a number of samples
then you can bound the difference
between the thing that we're doing up
the this thing and the Q star so let's
do our hat of Si plus gamma sum over s
prime transition the empirical
transition model s a b star of s prime
minus q star s a is greater than or
equal to minus beta divided by square
root n SI ok and this is going to hold
for all TSN a right so we've used
huffing and now we can relate the
empirical reward the empirical
transition model and if someone gave us
the optimal q2 what Q star is and then
now what we want to do is compare this
to what we're that equation up here so
I'll just write this is one so that
equation one up there is what we're
actually doing an MBI EB we keep doing
that over and over again until it
converges so we take our empirical
transition model we take our empirical
reward model we add in this bonus we do
value iteration until we converge and
what we would like to do now is to
compare what happens to that quantity
versus what is Q star and we want to
show that that quantity up there is
going to be greater than or equal to Q
star okay so we're gonna do that by
induction so the proof is by induction
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
get Q tilde I of s a be the I Federation
of value duration so this is using that
equation one so equation one up there
and we're gonna let V tilde if I equal
the for a value s just to be if we were
to take the max action of that Q tilde
okay for every state and action pair and
what we're gonna assume is that we
initialize optimistically and we're
gonna initialize Q tilde of 0 for SI
equal to 1 over 1 minus gamma which by
definition is greater than Q star is at
least as good as Q star so that's our
base case
again what is that what are we trying to
do we're trying to show optimism here
for MBIA B we're trying to say that if
we do this procedure with MBIA B we'll
be optimistic we're gonna do a proof by
induction and this is the base case so
we start off we initialize our cue tilde
optimistically and now we're gonna
assume that this holds so we're gonna
assume Q tilde I of sa is gonna we're
gonna assume that Q Tala IMS a is
greater than equal to Q star of Si for
the previous time step okay so we're
gonna all right so let's write out what
Qi plus one is gonna be Q tilde I plus
one is going to be equal to four si it's
going to be equal to our empirical
reward plus gamma some of our s prime or
empirical transition model times our V
tilde of I of s prime plus beta over
square root n si that's just the same as
equation one so now we're going to say
that this by definition is going to be
greater than or equal to R hat of si
plus gamma sum over s prime our
empirical transition model times the
true B star because that's our induction
inductive hypothesis we assume that this
held on the previous time point plus
beta divided by square root n si since
by by inductive hypothesis we assumed
that we knew what we have a base case
where this holds we're gonna assume that
a that hold on the previous iteration
and then the last part that we need in
here is that if we're this part we look
at this part versus this part okay so if
you rearrange this equation then you can
see
it our hat of si+ all this stuff is
greater than or equal to Q star of Si
plus minus beta screw and s so that
means that if we substitute that thing
in back in over here we can say this is
equal to Q star that's a minus beta over
screw and si plus beta squared n si she
called a Q star so now we've shown
optimism so the key idea is in that case
was to say we know that we're getting
that we're going to relate this to what
would happen if we had the true Q star
we'd show that if we know the true Q
star on the next time step then doing
this one step back up we can bound how
far away we'd be from Q star in terms of
our function beta and then we can do an
inductive type an inductive proof to
show that if we were optimistic on the
previous time step we can always ensure
that held at the beginning because we
used optimistic initialization then
we'll continue to be optimistic for all
the for the resulting Q Q hat Q star so
this proves optimism my questions about
that proof so that's the proof of
optimism the other key part and I won't
go through the other part in quite as
much detail but I'll talk about it
briefly at a high level the other really
important part is accuracy
I mean bounded I'll keep this up in case
in one store by date accuracy is really
important and the fact that you will
eventually become accurate is important
so the the intuition for this part is
that you can think of defining a couple
different well you can make your
defining things as being
unknown somebody want me to keep this up
or as everyone finished writing raise
your hand if you'd like it up okay so in
many pack proofs PI for finite state
action pairs there's this notion of
known s so what does it mean so known
state action pairs intuitively known
state action pairs are going to be pairs
for which we have sufficient data that
they're estimated models are close to
the true model so the intuition here
tuition si where R hat of Si and t hat
of si s prime given si are close to true
are si so intuitively if you get more
and more data for a particular state
action pair we know from HOF ting etc
that your estimated mean is going to
converge to the true mean and your
transition model is also going to
converge to the true transition model
and what we're doing here is we're
soaring a line in the sand and we're
saying when are things when do we have
enough data for state action pair that
we are satisfied with our empirical
estimates where we can bound how close
our empirical estimates are to the true
models and if things are close enough
then we know that using those allow us
to compute inner optimal policy so if
everything is known all si pairs are
known then we can show that the V of PI
star under your sort of empirical model
I'll denote that as hat so this is like
your empirical model minus V PI star and
I'll put this under your empirical model
via of your true model
this is bounded I can go through all the
details so that you saw a little bit of
this on the midterm this is often known
as the simulation lemma if things are
closed like if your models are closed
your transition model is close to the
true transition model and your reward
models are close to the true reward
model then if you use those to compute a
value function your value functions are
also closed which is a really cool idea
it's basically saying you can propagate
the errors at your empirical model into
the errors that you get in your value
functions and the errors you get in your
policies so you can sort of propagate
error you can go propagate predictive
error so this is this really nice of you
can say like if you have good predictive
error then you can end up with small
control error and the known state action
pairs are just providing a way to sort
of quantify whether you know what level
do you need in order to be good enough
and the good enough you need is going to
depend on what that epsilon is you want
so one really important idea is to think
about these known state action pairs and
what they allow us to do in terms of
defining some alternative MDPs
so in this case I'll erase this just how
you so you know how through some of the
parts of the proof would go for it I
won't go through all of it in detail but
I'm very happy to talk about it is we
can define two other sorts of mdps we
can I'd call an MD PM prime which is
equal which is a MDP where first s a
pair
it's R and T so it's transition and it's
reward dynamic its dynamics and its
reward model are equal to the true MDP
on si in known set else it's equal to
the M tilde model so these are where we
sort of start to define these slightly
weird MDPs
so this is a model that is not quite our
M tilde model that we're using to do in
that equation one which we have these
kind of like rewards plus bonuses plus
article transition model and it's not
quite the real model it's saying on
things that are known we're gonna use
the real world model again we don't know
what any of these are these are just
tools for analysis and then on state
action pairs which are unknown we're
gonna use this optimistic model just
defines an MDP and the reason that this
is useful is we can end up using it to
help figure out how does the MDP that we
have relate to the real MVP on state
action pairs that are known this is one
MDP we end up using for this and then
the other one is a similar one which is
M hat prime which is an MDP equal to M
hat so this is just the empirical
empirical estimates on K and equal to M
tilde on all others so on the known set
so this is an MDP where for the known
set we use our empirical estimates not
the true true s not the true models and
then we use M tilde on all of these
other ones so the idea is that we can
use these different forms of MVPs and we
can quantify how far off the value is
that we get by computing using our
RQ tilde versus the value on these other
ones and we can use it to basically do a
series of inequalities to relate the
value we get by executing our policy
versus the value we get in the true
world under the optimal policy so these
are the types of tools that allow us to
help prove accuracy on state action
pairs that we know about yeah yes so M
hat here is the empirical estimates like
that if you use just the counts of the
rewards then the counts the transition
but I'll M tilde is the empirical
estimates plus the bonus so the
transition model and these two cases
would be identical but this one would
have the reward bonus turn so
intuitively this allows us to help
quantify the accuracy the final thing
that I guess I just want to mention
briefly of how these types of proofs
tends to work is that we need this
bounded learning complexity we need to
make sure that we're not going to
continuously update our q function we're
not going to continuously run into
unknown state action pairs so the last
part is to sort of you know how would we
prove three which is bounded learning
complexity and the intuition for this is
a little bit like the general intuition
for optimism so the intuition for
optimism was to say if you assume the
world is awesome either the world is
awesome in which case you have low
regret in the case that PAC that means
if you assume the world is awesome it
really is awesome
that's like not making a mistake that's
like picking the really the action that
you pick is good so then you won't
suffer a worse than epsilon decision and
then we want to be able to say that the
times where you don't make mistakes or
when you do make mistakes where you pick
an action that's bad which is less than
epsilon close is bounded and that's what
this is about
and the key idea here is the
pigeonhole principle so the idea is that
if you think about you don't have to
have episodic mdps but if you had you
can think of dividing your stream of
experience into episodes and during each
sort of episode you can think about
whether it's likely that you're gonna
run into an unknown state action pair so
you consider what's the probability that
we reach an unknown state action parent
that remember an unknown state action
pair here is one that we don't have good
models of like we've only visited at
once or something so what's the problem
we gonna reach an unknown six right
state action pair in T steps so what we
can show in this case is that if this is
low this is small if small if that
probability is small
we're being near accurate near we're
being near optimal so if it's a really
small probability that you're gonna
reach anything that's unknown we can
show that on the known state action
pairs you're being near optimal so if
you're unlikely to reach anything that
where you have bad models of it you're
gonna be near optimal if it's large this
can't happen too many times so if it's
large you're gonna visit it
I can't happen too many times because if
this is large that means that you're
really likely to reach unknown state
action pair remember I said that for
every state action pair you only update
it at most M times so by the pigeonhole
principle this probability cannot stay
high for too long essentially you're
gonna have a function of like the number
of states the number of actions and M
its larger than that but this is saying
that you need to be able to visit each
state action pair M times so that that
goes into R and bound here if the times
we're gonna make mistakes and we where
we might sort of reach things that are
unknown it might take us more steps and
we might make some bad decisions along
the way but essentially things can only
be unknown for M steps for each state
action pair which means that our
ability here has to be bounded so
eventually everything has to be known or
you have to be acting near optimally and
that allows us to show that things have
things our pack it has bounded we're
gonna make a bounded number of bad
decisions so either we're not gonna be
reaching any part of the state action
space which is unknown so everything we
reach we have good models of them and
we're using them to make good decisions
or we are reaching things and then in
that case we're getting information
because we're getting a new observation
of what it's like to be in that state
action pair and we get only something
can only continue to be unknown until we
get M counts Hey do you mind putting
down the thing again
okay so that gives us an overview of why
MBIA EB is pack as well as sort of why a
lot of the types of proofs that you do
to show things are pack and I think the
the key ideas in this is really the sort
of notion of optimism and accuracy and
the ability to make progress ability not
to be stuck always wondering by
decreasing these confidence intervals
sufficiently fast okay so now let's go
back to busyness so that kind of
concludes the pack MVP part for awhile
there's been a lot of exciting recent
work in this area I guess let me see if
I can just really quickly brief it bring
this up um this is our firm a
presentation one of the CAS is giving up
at Berkeley today on some of our joint
work together just the highlight here in
terms of sort of pact and regret
analysis there's been a lot of progress
on getting better approaches so over the
last few years means of my guys students
some other really nice groups have been
doing a lot of work on this and we're
also now trying to have analysis that is
problem dependent which means that if
the algorithm has more structure and we
should need less data in order to learn
to make good decisions
so now let's be Bayesian and see how
being Bayesian helps us so we saw a
Bayesian bandits and amazing bandits we
said we're gonna assume that we have
some parametric knowledge about how the
rewards are distributed so we're gonna
think about there being a posterior
distribution over awards and we're going
to use that to guide exploration and we
particularly talked about this notion of
probability matching which is we want to
select actions with the probability that
they're optimal and it turns out that
Thompson's sampling allowed us to do
that so in these sort of approaches it
was very helpful if we have conjugate
priors which allowed us to analytically
compute the posterior over the rewards
of an RPR given the data we've observed
and our previous prior over the
probability of different rewards for
that arm so we saw as one example of
that the bernoulli which means that the
reward is to 0 1 and the beta
distribution and the beta distribution
is one where we can think of the alphas
as being counts that the number of times
we've seen a plus 1 and betas is the
number of times we've seen the
our being zero and as we get
observations of one hour of either of
those outcomes then we just update our
beta distribution so that allowed us to
define Thompson sampling for bandits
which was this algorithm where we say at
each time step we first sample a
particular reward for each of the
different arms and then we or we could
sample a reward distribution we compute
the expectation for those reward
distributions and we act accordingly so
we saw this for the toe example where we
saw that we would sample different
rewards and then use these two acts and
at least in that example we were seen
that we happen to exploit much faster
than what we were seeing with an upper
competence bound approach so a very
similar thing can be done in the case of
MVPs so now in being Bayesian for models
based RL we're gonna have a distribution
over MDP models so what's the difference
here that means we're gonna have both
transitions and rewards so we're gonna
have it the rewards should look very
similar to bandits so the rewards very
similar to bandits you can also use
betas if your award distribution is 0-1
you could also use betas and bernoulliís
so this is very similar to bandits T is
a bit different we're not gonna talk a
lot about the different distributions
you can use but for example if we're in
tabular domains T can be a multinomial
and the conjugate prior for multinomial
it'sa Dursley it's conjugate so if you
want your your transition models to be a
multinomial which is the probability of
where all the other states and actions
then a conjugate prior for that is a
Dursley which has a very nice intuitive
description similar to what beta is in
beta you could think of this as just
being the number of times you've
observed 1 or 0 if you look at it
Dursley you can think of this as being
the number of times you breed each of
the next states so s1 s2 s3 s4 so the
Dursley the
tribution is would be parameterize by a
vector for one of each of the states and
again we can use this sort of posterior
to update it to allow us to do
exploration so in this case we're going
to sample an MDP from the posterior and
then solve it so if we look at what the
algorithm looks like it's gonna look
very similar to Thompson sampling for
bandits except for now we're gonna start
off and we have to define a prior over
the dynamics and reward model for every
single state action pair so notice this
is this tabular or assuming that we have
a finite set of s and a so we can write
this down we can write down our we have
one distribution for every single state
action pair for both the dynamics and
the reward bottle and then what happens
is that you sample an MDP from these
distributions so for every single state
action pair you sample a dynamics model
and a reward model and now you have an
MDP and so once you have that MDP you
compute the optimal value for it so this
is obviously more computationally
intensive than what we had for bandits
but it's certainly a reasonable thing to
do and then you act optimally with
respect to the q star you have for that
sampled MDP so this is known as Thompson
sampling for MDPs it also implements
probability matching and empirically it
can often do really well just like
Thompson sampling did really well often
for bandits so I think that's probably
all I'll say about Tom's and sampling
for MVPs there's been a number of
different works on this just to
highlight some people that do some
really nice work on this from Stamford
Ben van Roy
Roy's group has done a lot of work on
this and sometimes they call it
posterior sampling for MD peas so people
like some of his former students like
dan russo and ian ozb and IANS now at
deepmind dan russo is now at NYU they've
done some really nice work in these
types of spaces yeah
like non tabular energy beans yes great
question so the question was whether or
not we can generalize this to non
tabular MVPs yes and I'll talk about
that in a second
but kind of poorly but yes that's the
goal all right anybody have any other
questions about sort of finite state and
action scenarios now we're going to talk
a little bit about generalization okay
all right so of course everything I've
just been saying right now is for finite
state and action spaces which is not
very satisfying because if we think
about these types of bounds I said this
was polynomial and the size of the state
in action space so what if s is infinite
I mean says we could make an infinite
number of mistakes and that seems sort
of unfortunate so it's not clear that
this initial framework is is it all
helpful when your state space is either
infinite or insanely large like the
space of pixels so even though the
framing of this is really nice we would
like to be able to take these types of
ideas up to generalization but we'd like
to figure out how to how to use them in
a way that can be practical now when we
start to so this is a very active area
of current research there's been a lot
of different ideas about this over the
last few years I do want to highlight
that on the theory side we still have a
long way to go as we talked about some
with function approximation even just
function approximation and doing control
like off policy control like q-learning
we said that we didn't have good
asymptotic guarantees for some of the
basic algorithms so if we don't even
have good asymptotic guarantees it's
unlikely that we would have really nice
finite these are often known as finite
sample guarantees because they guarantee
that the number of mistakes you're gonna
make is finite so we have relatively
little theory in this case that's
something that my group is working on
there's that several other groups that
are also working actively on this but
there's a lot still to be done but there
has been some really nice empirical
results recently okay so let's think
first about generalization and optimism
like optimism under uncertainty where
we're now in a really really large state
space so let's think about what might
need to be modified if everything was
extremely large we go back to this
algorithm well first of all we had this
these sort of counts that were we're
keeping track of sort of for every
single state action pair what what the
counts were so this isn't gonna scale
because if you're in a scenario where
your state spaces pixels you may never
see the same set of pixels again does
anybody have any ideas of how you might
extend this to the deep learning setting
like what we would like in this case is
some way to quantify our uncertainty or
uncertainty over sort of states and
actions but we don't want to do it based
on like rock helps because then
everything will just be one forever so
the citizen was whether we could do some
form of like a BFA for example yes we
could imagine trying to use some form of
some sort of density model or some sort
of way to try to either get an estimate
of how how much related information have
we say or how many related states have
we'd seen in this area yeah just was to
use some sort of embedding absolutely so
another thing you could do here too is
to do some sort of form of compression
of the state space one of the challenges
is the right compression the state space
depends on the decisions you want to
make and so generally it will be non
stationary but that's not necessarily
bad you might just want to go back and
forth between those so those sort of
ideas are great in general we want some
way to quantify uncertainty that it's
gonna have to generalize and say similar
nearby states if we visited that area of
the world a lot then we should have less
of a bonus on that in terms of optimism
okay so as I said these sort of counts
of Si and si s prime are not going to be
useful for only gonna encounter things
once another thing that I want to
highlight is the methods that I was
talking about before a really model
based a lot of the work there is model
based in contrast a lot less of the
things it's starting to change recently
over the last year but in general
there's been much less work on the
model-based approaches for a deep
learning in terms of RL and I think
that's because the model free and the
policy search techniques have generally
been much better
in part because the error that you make
in your models accumulates a lot as you
do planning and so I always remember
David Silver's first talk about this
were one of his earliest talks about
this from I think 2014 where he showed
this beautiful sort of model-based
simulation which was horrible for
planning so the errors really have to be
very good errors have to be very small
and it's not clear the the
representation you get by maximizing for
predictive loss there's always going to
be the best for planning so we'd really
like to be able to take the ideas we saw
before for things like MBI eb and
translate them over to the model free
approach and think about some way to
encode uncertainty in the deep neural
network setting so let's think about
doing something like cue learning I'm
like DQ learning and in this case so
I've been a little loose here you could
this could be a target so target could
fix this but think about something like
sort of the general cue learning and cue
target where we use the max of our
current function approximation or we use
the max of our current target function
approximation so one idea for inspired
from MBIA B would be simply to include a
bonus term so again this could be you
know a fixed target but the idea here is
that when you were updating your
parameters just put in a bonus term for
that particular state action pair when
you're doing your Q learning update or
when you're refitting your weights of
course we have to know what that Q bonus
would be but this would help with the
planning aspect so now we're in the
model free environment poor model free
setting and so we could when we're doing
our sort of Q learning updates let's
insert a bonus term so that's why I
chose MB ie B is the algorithm to show
you before because I think that those
sort of reward bonuses are much easier
to extend to the model free case now of
course the question is what should that
reward bonus be it's got to reflect some
sort of uncertainty about the future
award from that state action pair and
there's a lot of different approaches
that have been trying to make progress
on this so Mark Bellamy R and some of
the follow-up papers thought about sort
of having a density model trying to
explicitly estimate a density model over
the states or state action pairs that
you visited
other people have done sort of
hash-based approaches which is sort of
more similar to the embedding in a way
try to hash your state space and then
use those use counts over that hash
state space and then update your hash
function over time so that's some other
work that's come out of Berkley so
there's different different ways to
quantify this another thing I want to
highlight here is that these bonus terms
are generally computed at the time of
visit when we looked at MB IAB you could
recompute these later so if you if
you're storing things in your episodic
replay buffer you might want to update
those over time because those state
actions if you now later sample that
reward a next state pair from your
replay buffer you may want to change
that bonus term so there's a number of
different subtlety s when we tried to
bring this up to deep learning but
there's been some really encouraging
progress so let me just this so in this
case what we can see is the initial work
from mark Bellamy's group where we
compare on Montezuma's Revenge which is
considered one of the hardest Atari
games sort of the progress of a standard
dqn agent that was using a greedy
there's a number of different rooms and
montezuma's revenge in this case you can
see after 50 million frames it was doing
incredibly badly don't only been through
two of the rooms whereas if you use this
sort of exploration bonus this one did
much much better
it's just enormous ly better by being
strategic so I think that highlights the
empirical significance of doing this
sort of strategic exploration let's
think briefly about Thompson sampling so
in this case one of the ideas that we
did a few years ago is to say you could
do Thompson sampling both over your
representation and the parameters of
your model what do I mean by that I mean
that if you have a really large state
space you could imagine collapsing your
state's and doing a dynamic state
aggregation and sampling over possible
state aggregations as a way to sort of
do it collapsing your state space and
Thompson sampling can be extended to
sampling over representations so that
works well but it doesn't scale up fully
when you want to really scale up if you
want to be a model free it's a little
bit different than what we saw before
because before we saw model-based
approaches and now we're sort of wanting
to assemble from a post
/ possible cue stars and it's not clear
how to write that down I don't think
we've made good progress on that even in
the tabular setting but that's what
we're trying to do it people are trying
to do for the deep learning setting
there's been a couple different main
approaches one is again sort of from Ian
Oz band who was here for his PhD they
did bootstrap dqn the idea here is that
you couldn't use bootstrapping on your
samples and you can build a number of
different agents so now you kind of have
CQ values instead of just one Q value
and then you can act optimistically with
respect to that set it's not incredibly
effective it gives you some performance
gain another thing that we did a we sort
of we in some what I was working before
I was involved one of the earlier
versions of this and since then they've
been continuing to push it forward the
idea here is that you kind of fix your
embedding you do linear regression on
top and that is super simple but if you
do Bayesian linear regression you get a
notion of uncertainty and that actually
gives a lot of performance gains in a
lot of cases so you can sort of have
like a really little bit of uncertainty
representation on top of a deep neural
network but this is an active area
there's a lot of people thinking about
this different type of work and I think
it's going to continue to be a really
big area because we still haven't made
sufficient progress and how to do
exploration plus generalization so just
to summarize I know we've done quite a
lot of theory in this section the things
that you should have should make sure
you're familiar with is to understand
what is the tension between exploration
and exploitation in RL and why this
doesn't arise it on other types of
settings you should be able to define
these different sorts of criteria for
what it means to be a good algorithm in
terms of pact or regret and be able to
map the sort of algorithms that we've
discussed in detail in class to these
different forms of criteria so if I say
you know is this optimism under
uncertainty approach is that good for
pact or regret or both you should know
that it's good for books so that's the
kind of high-level that you should be
able to understand from the things we've
been doing and just know that there's a
lot of really exciting work that's
continuing to go in there including
defining new metrics of performance and
next time we'll hear about meta learning
Thanks